I got a hilarious email yesterday which
I want to share with you Liz wrote to me
and Liz said here's some feedback from
me I am a member when 99% of the world
refers to the virus as coronavirus does
it make you feel special and superior to
use the term kovat 19 repeatedly on your
show personally I find it irritating and
a sign of your arrogance it's a tell and
while I'm at it I will give you some
more feedback regarding your arrogance
your sexist dismissal of Suzy Ormond who
you obviously know nothing about so I'm
gonna ignore the Suzy Orman part I don't
even remember mentioning Suzy Orman
other than she's given some scammy
financial advice over the last 20 years
let's focus on kovat 19 so Liz noticed
this and other people also notice this
I've been avoiding the word coronavirus
in my stories and what I say I've been
avoiding it in YouTube titles and in
YouTube descriptions and the reason I'm
doing that is YouTube has notified me
that anything even mentioning
coronavirus is completely and totally
not monetizable so I've been trying to
find other ways to describe it sometimes
I'll say they're looking for a vaccine
for the pandemic virus or I'll say the
latest data in the virus outbreak
sometimes I'll say khob in 19
unfortunately these techniques also
aren't working and on Monday there was a
lot of coronavirus coronavirus news from
the weekend i'm saying it now because
obviously this video is is a lost cause
monday more than half of our show was
demonetized
even the stories that were mostly about
trump saying things where something
about coronavirus was like an aside even
those videos were demonetized I've told
YouTube I've told everyone of my
contacts at YouTube this is crazy
this is a public interest story this is
a public health story it's not gory it's
not violent it's not salacious we have a
pressing health concern and they say now
sorry it's not ad friendly and even
worse because not only are independent
media stories about the virus
not monetizable there are ads that run
on my videos people will get a pre-roll
ad on one of my videos from another news
outlet covering coronavirus which makes
no sense whatsoever so it's not
arrogance I'm not trying to make you
think I'm smart or anything like that
it's certainly not sexist or anything
like it it's that we have to cover this
it's an important issue it's a public
health issue and in doing so we lose
money so I'm creatively trying to get
around saying coronavirus so far it's
not working too well but for upcoming
stories that's why you might might see
me vaguely say the outbreak the virus or
sometimes kovat 19 if it's annoying I
apologize in advance I have an
unbeatable deal for my viewers for just
20 bucks you can get an entire year of
award-winning antivirus plus a VPN which
makes you anonymous online you can use
them both on three of your devices when
you use the link down below all made
possible by our good friends over at
total AV they're one of our sponsors one
of the most trusted names in computer
security I use total AV antivirus to
protect my desktop computer my phone and
my laptop you're using the internet on
any device that doesn't have an added
layer of defense you're opening yourself
up to all kinds of online threats total
AV antivirus helps keep you safe from
viruses spyware ransomware adware works
on Windows Mac iOS and Android it'll
protect your computer smartphone even
your tablet all of which are susceptible
to online attacks that can otherwise be
a complete nightmare to deal with take
it from me safeguarding yourself online
from this stuff is a lot more simple
than you might realize you just need an
anti-virus system like total AV that's
known for its reliability you install it
once it runs in the background you don't
even have to think about it and the best
part it's completely affordable right
now because they're offering 80% off to
our audience for just 20 bucks you get
total a v's premium antivirus on three
of your devices for a whole year and as
part of that deal you'll get totally
these very dependable VPN which makes
you anonymous when you're browsing the
Internet the VPN alone is worth the 20
bucks
check out total AV click the link right
underneath this video